one of my favorite ways to build EDH
decks is to chase a particular Vibe a
feeling that I want to infuse as much of
as possible into the DNA of a deck a big
instance of this was chasing the feeling
of raw power and inevitability granted
by big lands decks ramping myself into
being the Untouchable god king of a
particular EDH game however equally
alluring has been the exact opposite
type of deck a deck that can cultivate
the sort of low Toth ground Cutthroat
games that often characterize other
formats but which are frequently in EDH
on my end of things it's absolutely
possible to play that kind of magic I
can play a combat Focus to Deck full of
Scrappy two and three drops but the
issue is that this frequently doesn't
play well with the sorts of decks that
dominate most of the format life totals
are too high ramp is too plentiful decks
are designed to get too many resources
for a scrappy little pile of dudes to
keep up aggro can work but most often it
involves either Voltron esque methods or
a strong Commander such as torbrand
jetmir or ANM pacal as a core that binds
together an otherwise disjointed game
plan that would be fine but it wouldn't
be quite the sort of cage fight magic
Vision I was going for it would be me
racing a bunch of normal game plans
using my powerful Commander so what if
instead I went a different direction
what if I played a pile of little
scrappy dudes and then dragged the rest
of the table down to their level this is
where discard comes in discard doesn't
necessarily say yes or no rather it
strips away resources forcing my
opponents to pick and choose what what
they want to keep in hand and
disproportionately hindering decks doing
more synergistic or complicated things
when I first conceptualized this deck as
a $25 budget deck four years ago I went
with a bit of an oddball Commander
Choice malagor what's he doing here well
the logic is that with a 99 that is
focused on flexible two to three drop
creatures and three to four cost discard
spells there wasn't really a need to fit
a commander into my curve so a higher
cost utility option works just fine as
for the specific appeals of malagor well
I'll get back to that bit when I went to
finally update the 2020 version of the
deck this summer I started with a full
20 discard spells the goal is to get the
table hellbent and you need a lot of
discard spells to do that consistently
two spells ends up being a good number
to shoot for and a count of 20 allows me
to draw that within the first five draws
of the game approximately 75% of the
time which is good enough for my
purposes this gave a good starting point
for the deck but simultaneously posed a
problem 20 slots is a lot to spend on a
category of card that broadly doesn't
directly impact the board this brings me
to a key feature of the deck compactness
compactness is a feature I find
important in general and on a basic
level it just means that decks should
use their slots as efficiently as
possible so as not to overcommit
resources to accomplish tasks in this
case the deck manages to pack decent
quantities each of cards that consider
draw spells and cards that consider
removal spells in addition to the
discard this compactness can be seen
when I sort my categories by card type
on arched 11 of the deck's 14 draw
spells are creatures as are nine of its
20 discard spells and and five of its 14
removal spells this is critical because
it allows the deck to put on pressure
and keep a high creature count for
purposes of cards that care about that
while still spending a full 20 slots on
cards that Force opponents to discard
and 14 slots each on removal and draw my
rata deck does something similar I cash
in around 20 slots up front for ramp and
then the deck is as dense as possible
with card utility from there
specifically these decks both place a
high priority on draw and removal
running as many cards as possible that
give one of these things while also in a
different purpose such as being a beater
or an acceleration spell or a land this
is not done at no cost there are lots of
cards that are quite decent generally in
EDH that don't fit well into this
outline protection spells aren't very
compact because they need something to
protect in order to gain value Anthem
style cards aren't very compact because
they require a board of creatures in
order to gain value escalation cards
that amplify the power of certain
effects aren't very compact because they
require something to amplify to gain
value and Mana acceleration that is
efficient but temporary isn't very
compact because it requires a specific
follow-up plan to gain value none of
this is to say that these cards are bad
some of these are really fantastic
alongside other cards but that's the
issue they're not reliably helpful on
their own and the more of them you put
in a deck the more fragile it will be
each of these decks I just mentioned
mostly avoid these cards making an
exception for a small quantity of Life
gain because Staying Alive over the
course of a long game can be a challenge
for a deck that is grindy and compact
with the idea of compactness in mind
let's take a look at potentially the
greatest enabler of this concept in EDH
the eighth card in hand so to speak the
commander malagor is a six cost 66 flyer
who discards my hand and forces each
opponent to sacrifice a creature for
each card discarded this is an odd
choice of commander on the surface when
we look at popular commanders for
discard decks almost all are either an
enabler for making opponent's discard or
a payoff for making opponent's discard
like come on you're playing the
commander format the card that's always
available to you should relate to what
you're doing with your deck right
however malagor has proved to be an
excellent Commander choice for a few
different reasons for one malagor fills
a specific strategic Niche here one of
the main disadvantages of running a pile
of grindy creatures with discard effects
and draw effects attached is that these
creatures don't generally attack well
into chunky mid-range boards malagor
serves as a solution to this issue
providing a way to Blast Away blockers
and allow me to keep the pressure on
malagor effect also pairs fantastically
with discard effects normally opponents
might avoid overcommit to the board if
they don't have token to soak up some of
the sacrifice triggers from malagor
however with a stream of discard spells
opponents are pressured into making a
terrible choice either keep that awesome
creature in hand and risk discarding it
or play that creature and risk losing it
to malagor in this way malagor is an
example of what I'll call a
counterweight commander he subverts the
weaknesses of a discard Deck full of
grindy creatures thereby making the deck
better rounded instead of doing the same
thing as the deck he does basically the
opposite and the resulting tension
created by this allows for an almost
call and response esque play pattern my
board and discard spells prompt certain
play patterns for my opponents and
malagor exists to be my followup to
those patterns with a commander that
discards my hand on ETB this deck
naturally ended up needing to focus on
another Factor that's related to
compactness resilience what this means
is that a deck can recover from setbacks
readily challenges thrown its way can be
Shrugged off with relative ease this is
a good deck attribute to go for in
general it creates more positive play
experiences for everybody at the table
when deck can recover easily from
setbacks and most of my decks feature
this as a critical feature in some way
or other however this deck takes it to a
whole different level because it doesn't
wait for opponents to set it back oh no
this deck takes a baseball bat to its
own kneecaps of the de 20 discard spells
more than a third affect me as well and
as I've mentioned the deck's Commander
literally makes you discard your hand
nobody at the table is allowed to keep
cards in hand not even me step one of
this deck is that we're all getting
dragged down into the mud for some rough
and dirty Magic Gathering gameplay the
natural followup to this is that this
deck is specifically engineered to be
unusually good at playing under exactly
those circumstances I mentioned the next
draw being mostly creature-based and the
other important fact about the draw
Suite here is that most of the draw
spells are what I'd refer to as discreet
engines by discret I mean that these
cards largely don't rely on other cards
to generate card advantage and by engine
I mean that these cards give card
advantage over time one of these
requires a player to be hellbent to be
online which is helped by playing
discard spells or malagor and four
others require dealing comat damage to
players which can be assisted by
removing opposing creatures but the rest
kind of just hang around and provide a
stream of cards with minimal extra input
required this makes these a wonderful
type of card they're great as a top deck
they're great as a last card kept in
hand while playing a big discard spell
like delirium skaines and most are also
great to land on curve as well the other
thing that makes this deck resilient is
its graveyard package there are five
different cards that can recur things
from the graveyard and there are also
five cards that can be cast from the
graveyard or that can otherwise get
value from being in the graveyard in
some capacity there are an additional
five cards with Madness and another two
that provide benefits as a result of the
deck discarded cards and all of these
components combined to allow the deck to
somewhat mitigate the downsides of
discarding large quantities of cards not
fully mitigate mind you the deck still
gets to a hellbent state and feels it
but it has at least some tools to allow
it to play through that hellbent state
better than a lot of decks can in
addition an unexpected feature of the
deck has been that discarding one's hand
isn't entirely a bad thing see malagor
one with nothing ETB also has a social
benefit the deck's early turns are often
spent stripping away opposing hands and
this is a frustrating experience for my
opponents an experience that is only
Amplified when malagor comes down to
demolish some creatures as well looking
at the person who cleared out your hand
and killed your creatures would be
pretty upsetting if they still had a
full grip of cards and they'd be a
magnet for attacks and removal however
if they're also hellbent and have a
board entirely consisting of a 66 flyer
and some utility 33s well things aren't
as as clear I frequently gotten a
visceral sense of mixed feelings from my
opponents while playing this deck my
opponents wish I was the unambiguous
threat so they could have a good excuse
to attack me but I'm often barely ahead
at all and sometimes it's entirely
unclear to my opponents who is ahead the
threat profile of a low-slung grindy
deck is just not one most EDH players
are used to needing to consider what do
you do with a player who isn't an
imminent threat to your life total isn't
setting up for a combo and isn't scaling
up to an overwhelming late game the deck
is perfectly capable of winning games
through a mixture of attrition and
Beatdown but it manages to fly under the
radar much more than you'd expect even
after doing a bunch of nasty stuff to
its opponents in this way malagor is
critical to the deck for Vibes reasons
he is the key to Turning games from an
epic wizard duel into a knife fight
being fought in 4in deep mud for myself
and my opponents alike speaking of Vibes
let's talk about one of the oddest
conclusions of the deck building process
one of the exciting things about
upgrading this deck over the summer was
that I could finally play with waste
knot since the previous version of the
deck was an ultra budget list and since
there was now an enchanting Tales
reprint that was both cheap and super
cool looking I'm playing a discard deck
so a card that gives me various assorted
benefits When opponent's discard is a
perfect fit right however one of the
first games I played with the deck was
an utterly disgusting game for the card
turn two waist knot turn three arterial
flow and continuing onward and upward
from there it felt great from a power
level perspective the deck was keeping a
pretty full grip and accelerating
forward in its game plan even as the
rest of the table was struggling to keep
up under the weight of its discard but
something also felt very wrong about it
after a bit of reflection it became
clear what the problem was the whole
point of the deck was to play Scrappy
dragging the rest of the table down into
a fight in the mud and then being really
good at winning mud fights a big piece
of what made the deck work on a Vibes
level was that the deck had no Central
engine like waist knot it had a bunch of
little individual ones but none of them
were enough to be a loadbearing pillar
for the deck's game plan the fact that
Advantage is fought for tooth and nail
with a bunch of disconnected Little
Engines is a defining feature of the
deck and it's what makes the deck so
grindy and flexible this approach
contrasts with that of many EDH decks
it's quite common to feature a central
engine in the command Zone the commander
is the center of a Synergy pillar and it
has a number of other cards that
generate some form of value when played
alongside it when I go to the top
commanders around half of them follow
this mold ATT tracks that generates
value with counters cards ER dragon with
dragons yuo with ninjas Miram also with
dragons aen with attack ability
creatures jodo with legendaries you get
it in the best cases an engine Commander
is one that plays to the strengths of a
card type serving as an anchor for that
type that hopefully passes the vibe
check however not all engines pass that
Vibe check one example of an engine I
have mixed feelings about is Angie
Falcon wrath because she doesn't really
play to the strengths of Madness she can
enable them but the design of the card
is such that just chading through a
whole bunch of Madness cards while
paying for a few if any Madness costs
and then doing graveyard Shenanigans or
pulling off a combo is usually better
than focusing more heavily on casting
cards via Madness you could replace the
word Madness with a do nothing mechanic
called scrungus on both Angie and the
Now scrungus cards and the play style of
most Angie decks wouldn't change all
that much all this brings me to one of
my least favorite engine commanders and
one that is very similar to Wast knot
turrid God of fright turrid is
structurally speaking a pretty
conventional engine Commander maybe a
little feas or famine but in a similar
realm to something like Joda or Miram so
it exists in a normal-ish plane of
existence for an engine Commander but
counterintuitively this is exactly why
the card is one of the most hated
commanders out there see turrid is an
engine that works with discard and
sacrifice effects stealing and putting
into play all cards that get discarded
or sacrificed by opponents why is this a
problem well fundamentally it's due to
the nature of these tools discard and
sacrifice both have valid places in
Commander but they're tools that should
be used with a specific purpose in mind
casual Commander is naturally going to
involve a negotiation between what is
fun for other people and what makes for
interest in games the comfort of other
players at the table will be weighed
against other factors at least in some
form
the issue with using sacrifice and
discard effects as engine fodder then is
that these unpleasant tools become
frivolous and impassive equivalent to
just another filler dragon in a dragon
deck instead of deploying these tools in
a way that is targeted and strategic The
Turk player creates a bland engine
powered entirely by the suffering of
their opponents and is encouraged to
play as many edicts and discard spells
as possible rather than a number chosen
to fulfill a certain strategic role in
contrast to this my mordex hate tools
are run very intentionally with specific
goals in mind the deck runs a bunch of
discard spells because it needs to
kneecap opponents in order to not fall
behind in value and it runs malagor in
the command Zone because it needs a tool
to break through intimidating boards and
let its small creatures connect for
damage the benefits of opponent's
discarding and opponent's losing
creatures are mostly indirect with the
deck seeing benefits to its overall
strategy from these things rather than
having a bunch of cards that
specifically do things when opponents
lose cards impermanence in addition the
fact that the deck also plays low to the
ground means that opponents don't feel
like they're being smooshed into
submission while the discard player gets
to do some stupid exposive no I
don't get to play any sort of explosive
mid-range magic either that's just not
the sort of commander game we're playing
now does this mean that my maore deck
isn't going to make opponent sad
absolutely not discard effects and
especially discard engines like
bottomless pit are a form of stacks
effect and they will hinder my
opponent's ability to play the game
certainly my goal with this deck is to
change the shape and scale of the game
rather than preventing my opponents from
playing it I want us all to play a
scrappy top deck and cage fight of Magic
game rather than some thing where we're
all attacking resources constantly and
racing Synergy engines and the deck does
obtain this Vision some amount of the
time but the biggest weakness of the
deck in power and fun terms alike is
that certain opponents will be much less
harmed by my discard spells than others
see the power of non-random discard is
inversely proportional to the number of
cards in somebody's hand up until the
point at which that player has been
hellbent in a game if I make a player
discard a card when they are at five
cards in hand the quality of that card
will be much lower than if I force them
to discard a card at two cards in hand
the result of this is that if somebody
lands an early value engine and is able
to avoid dipping below three or four
cards in hand they're going to have a
much much better time than somebody who
was forced to go down to one card in
hand or fully hellbent even if the two
players discarded equal numbers of cards
over the course of the game in addition
decks with graveyard synergies are going
to be much better able to cope than
decks without the worst case scenario is
that I basically act as a king maker all
but handing the win to the person who is
best equipped to handle this card it's
rare that things are this dramatic but
has happened before and it feels pretty
terrible when it does is this a solvable
problem kind of the graveyard thing is
I've gradually pumped up the number of
graveyard hate cards to five and these
have actually been shockingly smooth
additions modern Horizon 3 contained a
couple of lovely flexible options and
imom Predator is another gravey engine
that has great extra utility as a
boardwipe resistant flying beater the
issue of draw engines is definitely a
trickier one though the amount of
Enchantment hate available in ratos is
currently pretty unimpressive and there
are also of draw that are harder to slow
down with removal that leaves the option
of single Target discard for when one
opponent still has a decent grip but the
others are puttering around with one or
fewer cards in hand him toar roac and M
twist are about as good as it gets for
single Target discard but these are
neither efficient in the early game nor
all that great as a top deck later the
other option is specters creatures that
Force an opponent to discard when they
connect for damage but these are also
largely not powerful enough to make the
cut hypnotic Spector is somehow both the
oldest and the most most powerful of
these and it's acceptable enough to be
an evergreen maybe board card but the
rest are pretty much all four drops I
wish for three drops or three drops that
I wish were Sauced up a bit with some
extra stats or keywords for the moment
I'll be keeping an eye on the problem
and potentially experimenting with some
of the single Target discard options
that do exist and for the future I'll
just hope that the card Gods at Wizards
of the Coast bless me with a new Spectre
that is more prepared for the demands of
2024 magic despite its challenges this
deck has been a success overall both in
terms of creating a deck on the right
power level for the games I want to play
and in terms of chasing the vibe I was
looking to chase I've known for years
that the malagor deck was my favorite of
the decks from the $25 pool with its
grindy to the max gameplay leading to
some really interesting games and I'm
glad to have maintained that with the
upgrade above all else it's an extremely
fun deck there is a calculated
recklessness with every play and it's so
fun to be able to play fast and loose
with both life total and cards in hand I
had a game recently where I played
malagor discarding my six card hand then
activated spy Master's Vault to py threw
some cards and put four plus one plus1
counters on bagore then swung 15 at an
opponent since I now had an anger in my
graveyard from all that discarding and
during all of this I was on five life
with two Dark Confidant effects on board
threatening to end me on each of my
upkeeps I survived more than two full
turn Cycles after this by the way lots
of lands happen to be on top that sort
of play is to me the defining feature of
the deck being able to throw all caution
to the wind to commit to plays as hard
as is physically possible and to find
creative ways to rebuild and come up
with resources after it looked looks
like I should be all of gas it's a play
style that is antithetical to my control
player roots and even a bit antithetical
to Commander as most people know it but
that's the appeal finding new and fresh
ways to play will always be a big goal
for me at EDH as we be creating Decks
that evoke a highly specific feeling and
this deck is certainly one version of
that that's the end of the video but I
have a very special announcement I
recently hit 50,000 subscribers which is
super cool and to celebrate I'm going to
be running a deck building challenge
through my Discord server Mala has
around 300 decks on Eda Trek as of
publishing this video which is quite a
small count for how cool the card is and
it occurred to me that there are a lot
of other similarly underappreciated
commanders out there that could use a
bit more love so for this challenge I
picked out five different monoc
commanders I like that have less than
200 decks on Eda treack those commanders
are aom Marshall of Rohan yomiji who
bars the way aegon god of death shizuko
caller of autom and Senator peacock to
participate in this challenge construct
a deck with one of those five commanders
then post it in the submission threaded
my Discord server within one week of
this video's upload so to be clear that
deadline will be Tuesday the 30th at
9:00 a.m. PST judging criteria will be
creativity cohesiveness and likelihood
to create Dynamic gameplay any power
level any budget my next video will
feature a deck me and my team determine
best fits the prompt for each of these
five commanders so you can keep an eye
out for that regardless of whether you
want to participate with that said
thanks for watching and if you want to
support me in doing what I do a link to
my patreon is down in the description if
you want more snail and don't want to
give me money I was on an episode of the
magic mirror podcast this week and me
and my co-hosts ranked each other's most
play decks it was a lot of fun and quite
interesting to see how my main six decks
stacked up in other people's eyes a link
to that is down in the description all
right that's all bye now